world championship and Olympic bronze
medalists spending seven hours in the
pool daily with one aim in mind gold in
Paris in 2024.
if they get there twin synchronized
swimmers vladder and Marina alexiva will
do so against the odds
displaced from their home in kharkiv
their former training facility shelled
to Rubble it is not just the destruction
of war that stands in their way but the
politics of international sport
for us it's of course not a low Russian
Sportsman without Russian anywhere yeah
it all creates uh first of all sports
it's it's for peace new guidelines from
the world Olympics body could see
athletes from Russia and Belarus
competing as neutrals
it's the international Olympic Committee
does in fact allow Russian and fellow
Russian athletes to compete at next
year's Olympic Games in Paris well then
it could cost many ukrainians deer the
government here is threatening to ban
its athletes from taking part if it
means competing with the Enemy
Ukrainian athletes have already paid the
highest price the war has claimed 262 of
the country's brightest competitors and
destroyed hundreds of sports facilities
the sisters are adamant their dream must
not be jeopardized further
we will do everything in our power not
to allow them into competition because
this is an immoral position
sport is about peace and there can be no
peace with Russian and belarussian
athletes competing
the Catholic Vladimir Andrew shook had a
glittering career ahead of him
his best friend dimitro says Vladimir
was widely tipped for Olympic success
next year it was says dimitro his drive
to win that led volodimir to join the
Army
all athletes are very strong people if
they don't have character and will they
will not last very long in sport and it
is that which makes them go to war to
fight for family loved ones and Country
follow Demir was killed in eastern
Ukraine in January another blow to the
country's Olympic hopes which his fellow
competitors are determined to keep alive
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Kiev